The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: While people
trickle in--
This slide is my attempt to
summarize what we said last
time, or you said last
time, mostly.
So it's basically, the movie
is making a case for
microfinance.
And the case is all these
different points.
They're building a case for
a particular version of
microfinance.
And they're making this
set of points.
They start with the point
that poor have
poor access to credit.
That they're reliable
borrowers.
That maybe group lending has
something to do with the
reliability.
That microfinance can lift
people out of poverty.
The way it does it is through
new businesses.
And the fact that this is these
new business generate
increased earnings of women.
Has the implication that there
is then greater investment in
human capital.
And finally, there is a implied
but also, I think,
important claim that there's
no conflict between the
commercialization of microcredit
and an emphasis on
its social role.
So those are the claims
being made.
So what I want to do today is
mostly go through the thinking
behind what's the argument
behind each of these.
And then try to look
at the data a bit.
So I'm going to now tell you a
little bit about an evaluation
we did of a program, of an
organization called Spandana.
It's a very traditional
program.
Their group liability, mostly
weekly payment.
Starting loan is about
10,000 rupees.
Interest rate was about 12%,
24% per year, really.
The way they calculate
is funny.
So it's 24% per year.
It was a very large MFI already,
but it had not
entered the city called
Hyderabad.
So the deal we had with them
was, they were going to enter
the city of Hyderabad,
but not everywhere.
Out of 104 poor neighborhoods
we selected,
they could enter 52.
And they'll keep the other 52
for 18 months untouched.
That was the deal.
So that's the Spandana group.
So this data is from 7,200
people who we surveyed.
7,200 households.
These households were selected
based on the fact that they
will be eligible for a loan.
It's not interesting
to compare people--
you could have also have
done something else.
But it makes sense
to select people.
Now, we didn't select them just
in the places which got
microcredit.
Because we wanted to compare
the places which got
microcredit and which didn't.
So we had equal numbers
of people.
3,600 people with these
characteristics where they got
the loan, and 3,600 with these
characteristics who
didn't get the loan.
Basic idea is to compare people
who could have got a
loan if there had been a
microfinance organization in
their neighborhood with people
who did get a loan.
These people are relatively
poor.
They have about a family
of five monthly
expenditure of $125.
Most of their children are
going to school, though.
They do borrow.
Many of them have loans.
When they borrow, 69% of the
households have loans.
But a lot of the households
that have loans from
moneylenders pay about
4% per month.
So Spandana charges 24% percent
per year, which is
less than 2% a month.
Because that's simple
interest.
2% a month simple interest,
which is substantially less
than half of that.
There's no MFI borrowing
at the beginning.
Lots of them run businesses,
31%.
That's a number to note.
Because you take the rich
country average.
The rich country average
is something like 12%.
9% run more than one business.
But these businesses are
extremely basic.
Like, I have a shop.
In the shop, I have bottles.
In the big bottles with
cookies, matchboxes,
cigarettes, and candy in them.
That's my shop.
I sell that.
Or I have a little push cart and
I sell vegetables on it.
So these businesses and not high
skilled, they have very
little capital, and they
have no employees.
Their profits are about $75
a month, so very small
businesses.
Like those.
When we asked them in the
beginning, why do you want to
get a loan?
A lot of them said what you
had already anticipated.
You might want to get a loan,
not just to start a business,
but also to repay a loan.
To do something for
your household.
To buy a fridge or a TV.
So they were quite candid
about the fact that they
didn't necessarily want
to start a business.
So, skip that.
So before we get into the
results, it's worth thinking a
little bit about what we
should expect to see.
And in particular, should we
expect people on average to be
consuming more when
they get a lot?
Yes, no?
Answers, answers.
There, yes.
Go ahead, explain.
AUDIENCE: If they intend to
start businesses [INAUDIBLE],
then you might expect that
they would tighten their
belts, or consumption in the
first two weeks of running it.
Therefore, their consumption
would go down.
PROFESSOR: You might think their
consumption would go
down as a result of starting a
business, because right now
I'm starting a business.
I don't want to start it on the
smallest possible scale.
I might want to buy
some inputs for my
business, expand it.
So when I start a business, I
might actually want to cut
back on consumption for a while
before I go back to.
Over time, it should
go back up.
But at the beginning, I might
very well see a fall in
consumption.
So that's an important thing
to keep in mind.
That if people are starting
businesses, they may
actually cut back.
So you may not see a
big net increase.
You'll see an increase.
If they start the business and
business is successful, then
two years later you'll
see an increase.
But not right away.
So here's the first problem we
had in this evaluation, which
is that despite the fact that
Spandana said they would not
enter these neighborhoods that
were put into control, the
loan officers did.
Why?
Because they thought, well,
that looks like a nice
neighborhood.
We could lend more to people
and make more money.
So they went in.
And we had to kind of fight
a lot to stop them.
And so in the end, the
difference in Spandana loans
was only 13%.
It should have been bigger.
Now, because that happens--
so some of the control
neighborhoods got the loans--
we're not going to be using the
actual fact of who got a
loan and who didn't
get a loan.
We're going to use the
intention to treat.
We'll compare places that we
thought should not have a loan
with places which we thought
should have a loan.
That's something that is
determined by randomizing.
Whereas who actually got
a loan was not random.
When the people went into
control neighborhoods, they
went into the best, in the
most attractive ones.
So we can't do that.
We need to compare ones which
actually got the loan.
And even worse than that, where
Spandana didn't go,
other MFIs went.
Because they wanted to
fill up the market.
So this difference is small.
So when you see--
why is that relevant?
Well, when you see the
difference, I'm going to show
you the average difference
between places that were
intended to get microfinance
with places that were not
intended to get microfinance.
Notice that that difference
is only 8%.
The places that were intended to
get microfinance were only
8% percent.
People there are only 8% more
likely to have a loan than
places that were intended
not to get microfinance.
So when I look at the average
of those places, what will
happen to the magnitude
of the effect?
It will be very small.
Because only 8% difference--
in either, both places, a
lot of people got loans.
So the difference was small.
So to get the real sense of the
magnitude of the effect, I
need to multiply by--
since it's 8% of the people
generated this difference, to
get the full effect of this,
what should I do?
To get a sense of the
magnitude, what
would I need to do?
If 8% generated an effect of 5,
what would the effect have
been if the difference
was 100%?
AUDIENCE: You multiply
by 100, divide by 8.
PROFESSOR: You'd multiply
by 100, divide by 12.
You would multiply by 12.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it the case that
you could look up what is
the average--
if there is no microfinance,
then it's 100% of the people
that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So you'll
do something that.
So when you look at the numbers,
they look small.
But you have to realize
that that's a
difference generated by--
the difference is generated
by a very small
difference in take up.
So these results are look much
smaller than they really are.
So here's what happened
in the business space.
There was some increase in
new businesses, which was
significant.
Some increase in profits, which
was not significant.
Some increase in revenues, which
But the new businesses
was significant.
So think of it this way.
This is the number of
businesses set up
in 1 and 1/2 years.
So basically, 31% already
had a business.
Another 7% set up businesses
in the treatment.
And 5.3% set up business
in the control.
So that's a 30% increase in the
number of new businesses.
So it's not small.
It looks small numbers,
but it's in fact
a significant increase.
In any case, people don't start
that many new business.
So is there was some effect.
Consumption.
Blue is always control,
yellow is treatment.
So consumption didn't really
go up significantly.
But we discussed why
that might happen.
You do see more durable
purchases, more business
durable purchases.
And I won't say what temptation
goods are right now.
So less temptation goods.
But you do see more business.
Here's what didn't happen.
Despite the gender nature
of spending,
apparently nothing changed.
So schooling is hard
to change, because
everybody goes to school.
So let's say that's difficult
to change.
But nothing else
changed either.
Children were just
as unhealthy.
Women were no more likely to
have decision power on
spending in the household.
And health expenditures
didn't go up.
So if you think that women spend
differently, we didn't
find any evidence of it.
So the gender effect that we had
discussed doesn't seem to
be in this data.
The next thing we did
is go back to that
story we were telling.
Me were telling a story where
some people would invest,
start a new business, and they
would cut their consumption.
Others will not start
their business.
And now they have no reason
to cut their consumption.
So imagine that the two kinds of
people, one kind of people
are going to start a
new business and
the other kind wont.
So what we want to do is we
want to predict who those
people are.
If we went to the treatment
areas and we looked at who
started a new business.
And we went to the control
area and we looked at who
started a new business, and we
compared them, would that be a
valid comparison?
Let me repeat the question.
Suppose I went to the
treatment areas--
the treatment area and
the control area
were randomly chosen.
I went to the treatment areas,
I found people there who had
started a business.
I went to the control areas,
and I found people who had
already newly started
a business.
And I compared them.
Would that be a valid
comparison?
AUDIENCE: May I ask
a question?
In the first example, when you
went to the treatment areas
did you study the people newly
started a business, or people
that had a business?
PROFESSOR: So when I say newly
started a business, these are
people who started a business in
the 18 months when we were
observing these areas.
AUDIENCE: No, it wouldn't
be valid [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Why?
AUDIENCE: And the reason why
is because, while you are
comparing new businesses
started, in the treatment
area, without more precise
information, it's hard to
understand who started the
business due to the fact that
they got the loan versus just
due to the fact that they were
starting it anyway.
And yeah, you could compare
a control area.
But even your control versus
your treatment area, it's not
necessarily indicative that
they had the same sort of
basis, [INAUDIBLE]
difference or differences of the
treatment area before and
after they got the loans.
PROFESSOR: You were
nodding your head.
Do you have a different
answer than that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So basically, I think
that's not quite right.
I think you don't ever
want to do it.
The reason you never
want to do it is
because you don't actually--
think of people who start a
business when I can't offer
them a loan.
Versus people who start a
business when no loans were
available or less loans
were available.
They're different
kinds of people.
When a loan is easy to get,
I might start a business.
But if loans are difficult
to get, I'm lazy, I
won't start a business.
Whereas somebody who starts a
loan when loans are not easily
available is probably
much more committed
to starting a business.
Is much one incentivized.
So you don't want
to compare them.
So what we had to do, we had to
think of what could predict
who would start a business?
Then what we could do
is we could split--
we could look for the kind of
people would start a business
in treatment.
And look for the same kind
of people in control.
So we could have a predictive
model of who
would start a business.
We could compare the things that
predict whether you start
a business or not.
So we want to divide the
population based on fixed
characteristics.
And the fixed characteristic
that worked very well is, if
you own land and if you have a,
typically a wife, a woman
in the household who is literate
and doesn't work.
So if you have some assets,
there's a woman in the
household who is currently
not working.
But she has skills, skills
she's literate.
She's actually a
prime candidate
for starting a business.
So it turns out that if you look
for families with these
characteristics in treatment and
control, there were equal
numbers of families in treatment
and control.
Not accidentally.
That's how you'd expect.
You'd expect randomly chosen.
So they are about the same.
So you take these kinds of
families, which are available
in treatment and control.
They're identical-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
instrumental variable?
PROFESSOR: This is not an
instrumental variable.
It's just predicting who are
going to start a business.
Then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create--
this is like baseline
characteristics.
They're just different people.
I can estimate the treatment
effect for
any subset of people.
I could say what's the effect
on tall people?
This is just take a subset of
the population who are with
these characteristics that
predict a business.
Those people's consumption, does
it do behave differently
from the consumption
of everyone else?
That's the question
I'm asking.
If these are people whose
characteristics predict that
they will start a business, do
they behave differently from
everybody else whose
characteristics predict that
they won't start a business?
So there are three groups
I'm going to look at.
People who's characteristics
predict they will start a
business, people who already
have a business, and people
neither have a business nor
will start a business.
So that's what I'm trying to.
And if you do it, you do
see the difference.
In the treatment, the people who
are who we predict should
start a business are much more
likely to start a business.
The people who predict shouldn't
start a businesses
are actually slightly less
likely to start a business.
So that's sort of what
you'd expect.
And now you start to see much
bigger differences.
So the people who start a
business and people who
already had a business, expand
their businesses.
Or they buy durables.
The people who didn't have a
business and don't are not
planning a business-- so
durables can include, for
example, business assets.
They can repair the house
where they're
going to have a shop.
So all those things
are durable.
So they seem to do stuff
that could be
related to the business.
The people who we predict should
not start a business,
don't start a business.
And they don't make any
durable expenditures.
They increase non durable
expenditures a lot.
So the bottom group increases
non durable expenditures.
That's like spending on food,
and things like that.
The middle group, basically
nothing changes.
And the top group cuts
non durables.
They're eating less.
These people are spending
less on food,
they're buying more durables.
The durables are what they
want for the future.
So they seem to be behaving
in very different ways.
So finally, this thing
of temptation goods.
What are temptation goods?
Well we asked people.
This is a beetle leaf cellar.
So people in South Asia and
Southeast Asia chew these
leaves and these nuts, which
are called beetle nuts and
beetle leaves.
They have slightly narcotic
effects, mild narcotic
effects, and a lot of
people chew them.
And this guy's a vendor.
He's a small business owner.
So we asked people in the
baseline to tell us, what are
things you want to give
up on spending?
So we asked them to give us a
list of things they said they
want to give up.
And that was basically
very simple.
They want to give up on tea,
coffee, snacks, beetle nuts,
cigarettes, and alcohol.
That's all they wanted to.
These were the things they
wanted to give up.
Now we go back two
years later, and
we look at the data.
And we classify spending
on these things
versus everything else.
These things we called
"temptation," because they're
things that they say they don't
want to do, but they end
up spending on.
And what you see quite
dramatically is that that's
where you see a big
difference.
The people who are starting a
business cut back massively in
their spending on temptation
goods.
The people who will never start
a business seem to be
having a party.
They go out and they start
spending more on those things.
So basically what's going on
for many of these people is
they're turning their temptation
expenditures,
they're using that money to
pay the loan payment.
And then with the money, they're
buying something else.
So when they get the money, they
either buy a durable or a
business durable.
They expand their consumption,
their durable ownership, and
then they pay down by
cutting back on
their temptation goods.
So they're drinking less tea and
they're owning more TVs,
if you like.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
less on temptation goods than
those who were taking loans?
PROFESSOR: Because these people
are starting a business.
They need the money.
AUDIENCE: No, but in the control
group also they are
starting new businesses?
PROFESSOR: No, they're
much less likely.
Remember, these people
have high
propensity to start a business.
Nevertheless, in control,
they're much less likely to.
They're only half as likely to
start a business in control as
in treatment.
So these people are much more
likely to be people who
started businesses
in treatment.
OK, so that's sort of the--
now, this is a story
which is--
it depends on the--
So when we published these
results, the reaction from
microfinance industry was
very negative, largely.
They thought these results
were showing
that they had failed.
And it really went ballistic.
There was lots and lots of blogs
which explained how we
don't understand how to
analyze microcredit.
On the World Bank's website
there where dismissive
statements, and all that.
So there were lots of these
things basically claiming that
microcredit is too subtle
to be analyzed by us.
So why was the reaction?
We actually didn't think this
was so negative, in fact.
We thought this was fine.
New businesses went up.
The people we thought would do
better were doing better.
Some people were doing worse.
That's normal.
If you give people a loan,
not everybody is
going to use it well.
Some people are going to use it
in ways that will get them
into trouble.
Others are going to use
it very well and
do well out of it.
And you're always creating
some risk when you create
financial products.
But people really hated these
results, and so we
got some push back.
[INAUDIBLE] went away
for a sad way.
What happened next was
that-- so this was
going on through 2009.
When the results came out, there
was lots of push back.
And then side-by-side
with that, something
else started happening.
And that's sort of
unfortunate.
So the next thing that happened
was that in 2009--
I guess both in 2009, once
in an organization called
Compartamos in Mexico
had an IPO.
You know what an IPO is?
An initial public offering.
They sold their stock.
And they made a ton of money.
And an organization called SKS
in India, which we actually
worked with on something else,
not microcredit, then went
ahead and they had
another IPO.
These IPOs raised a lot of
money, like hundreds of
millions of dollars.
And the reaction to that was
correctly, this means these
organizations are
very profitable.
Suddenly, everybody got
upset with them.
Because they realized that if
these companies can be sold
for $300 million, then they must
be making a lot of money.
Now that's a bit unfair.
Because they were making a lot
of money, but they also had
lots of clients.
And if you have three million
clients, then making $300
million over the next 20 years,
or something, is not so
much after all.
It's not that much money.
If you think, I have 3 million
clients, I'm making $300
million, that's $100 per client
over the next, let's
say, ten years.
So that's $10 per year per
client, which is not nearly as
profitable as it sounds when
you say it's $300 million.
Because these are big
organizations,
many of them are.
So in any case, that got them
into lots of trouble.
So first thing that happened was
that a lot of microfinance
people started getting
very upset.
Mohammad Yunus, who
started Grameen
Bank, was really vehement.
He called them the
new userers.
And basically said that this
commercialization of
microfinance goes against the
spirit of microfinance.
So that was already trouble.
Because there was divide
in the community.
What happened after
that was even--
so they said.
We have a minute.
So they said what we're trying
to do, we're doing an IPO
because this is the best
way to raise capital.
When we raise capital, we have a
lot of equity, we can now go
and borrow a lot based on
our equity, and then
we can expand lending.
So instead of 10 million
people, 100 million
people can get loans.
So they were making the case,
like in the movie, that we
really need to go in
this direction.
So this was a fight going on.
Then what happened,
this goes into the
beginning of 2010 now.
So there is two fights going
on through 2009.
One is basically against us.
And another set of results by
Dean [INAUDIBLE], who's at
Yale, also showing small
positive results.
But microfinance companies
didn't like the small positive
results and they didn't
like these IPOs.
Then what happened is
that a number of
people committed suicide.
A number of people in India, in
one state of India, which
is called Andhra Pradesh,
committed suicide.
Some of them claiming that it
is because their loan burden
was too high.
It turned out that they had
borrowed from six or seven
different microfinance
organizations.
And they couldn't repay, and
they committed suicide.
And at that point, all these
forces kind of lined up in
exactly the worst possible
way for the industry.
First, there were these
suicides, second there was a
fight within the industry, and
third there were these results
showing that they hadn't done
something so great.
And the net result was that
there was an attempt to
basically, there was a political
attempt, to shut
down microcredit.
And that's still continuing,
in the sense.
And what I want to end
on is showing you a
video, which is--
so BBC, as you saw a video that
was very pro microcredit.
I want to show you a video
that's more recent and much
less pro microcredit.
Where is it?
So you can see that you can
have unfair views on
any side you want.
You can make, that's a hatchet
job, if you've ever seen one.
So main point being that
I think that--
I only want to end on
this one point.
Which is that if you look at
this study, it does exactly
almost the same job
of very similar.
The [INAUDIBLE]
strategy is very similar.
I go to some person
in some village,
something bad happened.
That means that this
thing is bad.
You just look for the people.
And in some ways, I think
this has been
the industry's problem.
And the reason why that guy
got nailed so badly is
because, instead of saying that
this is something that's
useful, and we should find out
how useful it is, this started
by over selling.
And then they're easy target.
Everybody now is--
it's like, if you oversell,
people have high expectations.
Then you don't deliver, they
get very upset with you.
And so that's what they're
paying for now.
And this is like exactly
what you'd expect.
It's the reason why we were
trying to persuade them for at
least seven, eight years that
they should have a randomized
evaluation.
I remember going to an MFI and
explaining that they should
have a randomized evacuation.
They should show that they have
evidence of the impact.
And the guy told me, he was
an interesting character.
He was a Canadian who had
started an MFI in rural India.
And he was clearly not doing
this because he was making
more money.
He was dedicated to the cause.
He was living in rural
India, lending people
who were buying cows.
But he basically got so
upset with the idea.
He said, when you buy an apple,
you don't look at the
evaluation of that.
People are buying credit,
we are selling it.
What's wrong with that?
And so he just threw us out
of his office, basically.
But I think that's
their problem.
Their problem came from
the beginning.
They just pushed back on any
possibility that you want to
make a reasoned view
of these things.
And then, in some ways, that
creates the problem.
Yeah.